keeping schools safe from covert 19.
vaccines are one defense but most kids
are still waiting for the jab
in the meantime testing is critical
children often don't develop severe
cases of the coronavirus
but they can spread it putting teachers
and families at risk
antigen tests have so far made the grade
but is there a better way to stop the
spread of the disease
i'm ben fazel and welcome to the show
some german schools are now using the
lollipop test
sounds like fun not all pupils are so
enthusiastic about it
but better than a long swab up the nose
are you all ready 30 seconds go
then it starts the lollipop song
for 30 seconds the children at this
elementary school in cologne
suck on their lollipops
which are actually cotton swabs the
swabs
then go to a lab where they are tested
for covet
this new method aims to make testing
easier for young children
and it's quite good it's definitely
better than the nose test
i find it's quite handy because
afterwards i feel safer about whether or
not i have corona
but the taste is disgusting i always try
to think of lollipops afterwards
but the taste still doesn't leave my
mouth
back a cab takes the cotton swabs to the
lab
it's a logistical challenge because
another 500 schools
are bringing their tests here
in the lab the swaps are tested using
what's known as the pooling method
this means all cotton swabs from one
class
are evaluated together in one test
this is because the lolly test is
expensive the state pays around 50 euros
per analysis 9820
if you take 20 swabs representing 20
students
and divide them by 50 euros then you get
a good price
additionally you would have to add the
costs for logistics
and the materials that are used but i
think we're absolutely competitive
with the rapid tests
if the pool is positive individual
retesting is required
generally the lab doesn't deliver the
results until the next morning
but that would still be early enough to
break a potential chain of infection
says anegrit cavada
we are multiplying the genetic material
of this virus by a factor of 30 trillion
this means that you can recognize a
virus activity
when it is very low and not only when
someone is highly infectious
and already spreading their virus load
amongst their peers
here at the elementary school several
infections have been detected at an
early stage
using the lolly test although covered
cases are currently declining in germany
the kids will continue using the test at
least until the summer holidays
is head of the tuberculosis program at
find the foundation for innovative new
diagnostics a global alliance for the
sector
in some places in the world kids are
being tested before
all adults are fully immunized but only
in some
in the meantime attests an alternative
in preventing the spread of covert would
you say
definitely testing is really one of the
most powerful tools we have to
control the spread of covet we can use
the test to diagnose new variants
and it protects those who are not
vaccinated and you know to control
outbreaks you need to test to trace and
to isolate
and as long as the kids are not
protected by the vaccines
we need these accurate affordable and
child friendly testing strategies
and we saw some more effective or
efficient ways of doing it there in
cheaper ways is testing children though
any more challenging than testing adults
definitely the challenges are are really
many as
as one of the kids said today the the
nasal swabs they are very unpleasant
and it's often not easy to convince the
kids to uh to get tested
so if the child is uncomfortable with
the situation it runs around and then
the sample quality might be
below and then the test is is unreliable
so the lollipop testing approach is
really an efficient way to get a lot of
of kids tested at the same time so so it
makes more sense than than you
the usual nasal and throat swabs are
there are there any other
alternatives in development
well there you know there are many
different ways to
uh to test and uh
we are constantly looking for for less
invasive methods
like uh the nasal swabs not that the
ones that go further in
but we're also looking at new
innovations and through funding from the
german government
we're looking into for instance face
masks
where we capture the the virus in the
mask
other groups are looking at artificial
intelligence where you
when you cough into your smartphone and
then you have an interpretation
you can use smart watches to monitor
temperature so there's a lot of things
in the pipeline so i work a lot on
testing for children in tuberculosis
and one of the challenges we have here
is that rely on the sputum so that's
the stuff you cough up from the lung and
it's really difficult for children
so here we actually have to sometimes
put a tube into the nose and into the
stomach
and it stays there for three days then
you wash the stomach
for for the back and get the bacteria up
there so
we've used stool or the poo of the child
as an alternative sample and it works
quite well so you know
different diseases have different
challenges and children are always
the hardest group and we need really
yeah new recent
research and development to make this
happen but i'm sure a lot of people
including kids would uh be quite
enthusiastic about the multitasking mask
can can you tell us more about that how
effective that would be
well it's early days and uh there's a
lot of research being done at this
at the university of leicester in the uk
and by other groups
and it's only being explored in humans
sorry in
in adults at the moment and yeah so
we're seeing good results for covet we
are
starting to see the best uh new results
coming up
also for for tb so so clearly it's an
opportunity
uh to potentially test for multiple
diseases
uh using this approach and you know once
we out of covert
it might be useful for eyes virus or flu
or
that kind of thing but more than whether
or not we're talking about
little or big human beings uh the thing
about
rapid tests is that they're quite likely
to deliver
those false positives we've so often
spoken about on this show
is there any way around that
well you know there are we are looking a
lot
at trying to find simpler and affordable
tests and
it's very important to to always have
evaluations that
compare different tests against each
other so you actually choose the best
kind of test in each class and we're
working here with with partners across
the world to
to make these independent evaluations
for instance
university clinic in heidelberg and and
charlotte in berlin
and you know some tests are better than
others and well we basically need to uh
to try new approaches and
yeah for me the lollipop approach really
seems to be a great invention with
for the situation right now in in
germany with with a relatively low
incidence it seems the right thing to do
modern
their head of the tuberculosis program
at find the foundation for
innovative new diagnostics with some
innovations in testing and the
importance of testing for children thank
you very much
thank you your turn now here's
derek williams with a view a question on
vaccines and variants
are the current vaccines causing
selective variants to search
this is another of those internet rumors
that's gained some traction
in the last few weeks because somehow it
sounds
like it might be kind of plausible but
it actually isn't um
to explain why i have to go over
some of the basics again um all viruses
evolve randomly over time as they
replicate
and a miniscule number of those
mutations will prove
advantageous let's say that one of them
makes a mutant
a lot more transmissible in humans voila
a potentially dangerous new variant
over time that variance offspring
could start to supplant earlier versions
of the virus simply because the variance
spreads
to more unprotected people in a
population
within a shorter period of time because
it's more transmissible
so when you start to look for that
variant specifically
in that population you see increasing
numbers of people
getting it a surge but that's an effect
that can be traced back to the variance
ability
to spread faster in people with no
immunity
not something that's caused by or or
driven by
vaccines what vaccines do is turn
unprotected people into protected people
with immune systems
that are quickly able to shut down any
subsequent
infections with sars kobe 2 whether
that infection would have been with a
fast spreading variant or or a slower
spreading one in other words
they keep us from turning into virus
factories where the pathogen
can replicate a lot and and the less the
virus replicates
the fewer chances it has to mutate
so in the long run vaccines will
actually help prevent other potentially
dangerous new variants
from arising by slowing and stopping
the spread of sars kobe 2 and
drastically reducing
the number of times that it's able to
make
copies of itself
[Music]
finally we asked children aged between 6
and 15
in dozens of countries to take part in a
project recording their impressions of
the crisis
we leave you with their drawings that
not only convey their sadness and
loneliness but
also the admiration they have for
doctors and nurses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
food
[Applause]
[Music]